la policía alemana irrumpió el miércoles
en heladerías de todo el país pero no
precisamente para refrescarse con un
helado
se sospecha que las tiendas son centros
de blanqueo de dinero utilizados por la
entrangueta el grupo mafioso más
poderoso de Italia y las redadas forman
parte de una operación coordinada escala
europea apodada eureka
siguen no es San Lucas pero aunque hace
menos calor los helados también se
venden muy bien aquí lo que no toleramos
es que una heladería se utilice como
servicio de blanqueo de dinero
los que se dedican a negocios ilegales
como el tráfico de drogas y el blanqueo
de dinero ya no estarán calentitos sino
helados
según europol la operación en la que han
participado más de 2.700 policías afecta
a varios países europeos además de
Brasil y Panamá se incautaron bienes por
valor de 25 millones de euros y el mayor
número de detenciones tuvo lugar en
Italia con sospechosos acusados de una
serie de actividades delictivas
incluyendo fraude fiscal
proporción y blanqueo de dinero pero la
principal acusación es el tráfico
internacional de drogas desde Sudamérica
ya que el grupo delictivo controla la
mayor parte del flujo de cocaína que
entra en Europa
sus actividades delictivas sospechosas
son la participación en varios envíos de
droga principalmente cocaína entre
Sudamérica y Europa occidental y el
blanqueo de las ganancias a través de
varias empresas legales lo que establece
un vínculo directo entre este dinero
procedente de la droga y la economía
ilícita
además de las heladerías los beneficios
del embragueta se reciclaban a través de
inmobiliarias restaurantes y lavaderos
de autos arraigada en la región
meridional italiana de calabria
vendrángueta es una de las mayores redes
delictivas del mundo con operaciones en
más de 40 países